before we begin to understand how
special identities can be used to
factorize polynomials let me write them
down for you the first one says a plus B
the whole squared equals a squared plus
two a B plus B squared the second one
says a minus B the whole squared equals
a squared minus two a B plus B squared
how do we use these identities to
factorize polynomials look at this
example 9m squared plus 12 M plus 4 can
we factorize this expression further one
way in which we can do it is to find the
highest common factor of the three terms
but if you observe carefully the HCF of
the terms is 1 is there any other way to
factorize the polynomial the first term
is 9m squared we can also write it as 3m
the whole squared the third term in the
polynomial is 4 it can be written as 2
squared we basically wrote the first and
the last term in whole squared terms why
are we doing this this is our first
identity a plus B the whole squared
equals a square plus 2 a B plus B
squared we got the first and the last
terms in this form now we look at the
middle term how can we write 12 m can it
be written in terms of the first and
last term and in this form yes we can
write it as 2 x 3m x to observe how we
split the middle term we made sure that
these two terms are present and the
factor of two is also present so we
rewrite the polynomial as 3m the whole
squared plus 2 x 3m x 2 plus 2 squared
does this expression look familiar to
you look at the first identity our
expression looks
exactly like the right hand side of the
identity where a would be 3m and B would
be two so a plus B the whole squared is
equivalent to three M plus 2 the whole
squared 9m squared plus 12 M plus 4 can
be written as 3 M plus 2 the whole
squared we could successfully factorize
this expression using the first identity
the question is how do we know that the
first identity has to be used it's
simple look at the first and the third
terms they have 9 and 4 both can be
written in squared form and the sign of
the middle term is positive so the
moment you see such terms remember that
the chances of using the first identity
are very high and if the middle term was
negative we would have used this second
identity now that we are done with the
factorization we should check our answer
we solve the factorized expression and
see if we get the original expression 3
M plus 2 the whole squared can be
written as 3 M plus 2 multiplied by 3 M
plus 2 and we use the distributive
property to expand the brackets we
multiplied this with this and this with
this we get 9m squared plus 6 M plus 6 M
plus 4 we add the like terms to get 9m
squared plus 12 M plus 4 which is our
original expression our answer is
correct 9m squared plus 12 M plus 4 can
be written as 3 M plus 2 the whole
squared
you